we just flew back from pax and pour our
arms tired nope nope nope not making
that dumb joke but our hands are a bit
tired from playing a bunch of great
games you might not have heard about so
here are seven of our favorites that you
might want to put on your radar first up
black future 88 though maybe they should
call it black Future 18 because you only
have 18 minutes to get to the top of a
procedurally generated tower and kill
the bad guy before your heart explodes
but you'll probably be dead before that
happens anyway so yeah the game is all
about taking multiple runs up the tower
switching weapons every chance you get
and the fact that it has a great art
style and synth soundtrack is just icing
on the indie cake city of brass is
another game where you'll be making
multiple runs but this time it's to the
center of a fabled Arabian city full of
treasure you've got a sword you've got a
whip and you've got a bunch of enemies
and traps to get past if you're hoping
to reach the end the randomly generated
stages only get tougher the closer to
the middle you get and if the look or
gameplay kind of reminds you of Bioshock
that's because it's made by a team of
developers who worked on that series -
speaking of games that remind you of
other games the messenger does for Ninja
Gaiden what shovel Knights did for
Megaman and that's kind of all you need
right there I mean come on who doesn't
love this little guy anyway the
messenger starts as a deceptively simple
8-bit platformer but later on turns into
a much more elaborate 16-bit game and if
you think that's the last twist it has
to offer you'd be wrong expect to see a
bunch of clever uses of the time and art
swap during your adventure that's not
the only side scroller with a great look
either dark devotion puts you in the
shoes of a Templar exploring a
mysterious temple but here's the thing
every time you open a door and choose a
path inside the temple the door closes
behind you there's no going back but at
least you can loot weapons and relics
along the way faith is also a tangible
substance for your Templar who can use
it to open chests and unlock secret
paths just be careful not to lose your
faith both figuratively and literally
let's relax a bit now the stillness of
the wind is definitely the calmest game
on this list and it's all about taking
care of goats the elderly tall
is the last person living in her village
and you can guide her through her daily
routine of raising goats making cheese
growing vegetables cooking meals and
trading with the merchants and yet
there's still an air of unease here
since this way of life probably can't
continue for much longer
you can also set out with donut county
this puzzle game definitely reminds me
of Katamari where you collect objects to
grow bigger and bigger but instead of
rolling a ball you maneuver a little
hole in the ground the more stuff you
swallow the bigger it grows and you can
even solve puzzles using the items
you've got up swallow in Adobe oven for
example and you'll be able to use the
heat to send a hot air balloon into the
sky let's finish up with one more game
that's also about dropping objects into
holes if you're tired of my segues don't
worry this is the last one pool panic is
much more than a simple game of
billiards each level introduces some
crazy new concepts like bear balls that
growl at you whenever you try to cue up
but your goal is still to knock each
ball into the pocket of course you might
find some hidden balls and even more
bonus stages along the way too and
you've gotta love the look of it you can
just tell this as an Adult Swim joint so
there you have it
7 of our favorite games from PAX East
2018 if you saw something you loved that
we didn't talk about here tell us all
about it in the comments and if you have
your own thoughts on our picks let us
know
you